this former Trump White House chief
strategist executive chairman Breitbart
news mr. Bannon
where were you one year ago tonight I
was with the president in the war room
on the 14th floor of our campaign
headquarters and then went up to the
residence when I got closer to to
victory all right let me ask you about
yesterday because you have been very
outspoken you're tired of weak
Republicans but more importantly they're
trying to say last night was a
referendum on Donald Trump
true or false well it's definitely false
I think what what we had is an
establishment candidate Ed Gillespie won
a primary very hard-fought primary
versus Corey Stewart and then really
didn't try to embrace President Trump or
really the Trump program until very late
we just kind of you know basically
talked about some of the issues which I
thought you know he should try to do
more of you know he never invited
President Trump I think he had President
Bush campaigned with him Marco Rubio
condi rice but he didn't invite
President Trump he really didn't invite
Cory Stewart who really is the titular
head of the Trump movement in Virginia
so I think there are a lot of things
that Ed Gillespie could have done and I
think in hindsight he wishes he had done
to generate more enthusiasm out there
among the Trump faithful to kind of
turnout and I think the race in Virginia
look we've lost by five points you know
I'm a Virginian and I never had a lot of
confidence it was never in our battle
plan that we were going to win Virginia
I thought even with Donald Trump the
head of the ticket we would get to win
one or two points we lost it by five
points
I mean Virginia because of Northern
Virginia is really not a purple state
more it's it's a blue state when Donald
Trump wins three hundred and four
electoral votes and when states like
Wisconsin Michigan Pennsylvania Ohio
Iowa it comes within one point in
Minnesota when he loses Virginia by five
points it shows you how it is so what is
the lesson less be needed to embrace
Trump much more now we know that the fix
was in
Trump was right Bernie Sanders she the
system was rigged I'll use Donna
Brazil's words in the primary she also
tried to fix the general election though
because now we know Clinton herself paid
for the phony Russian dossier that
others was spreading around all these
lies Russian lies that she paid for the
pick
was in there the fix was in Comey rights
or exoneration before he ever did an
investigation the fix was in on the
tarmac when Bill Clinton met with
Loretta Lynch there's a lot of fixing
the Clinton is involved in your reaction
after the fact well well you know a ga I
an organization I was the chairman of we
did the Clinton cash book and actually
drill down on uranium one to find out
all the nefarious activities around that
that we hope that Grassley's Judiciary
Committee and eventually the Attorney
General Sessions oh I hope he appoints a
special counsel a special prosecutor to
go after that but I think what you see
in the Democratic Party right now the
corruption of it is you know we started
a civil war in Sean you've been kind of
part of this for the last really eight
or nine years against the Republican
establishment that's our Eric Cantor got
blown out as a majority leader that's
how John Bainer
got sent home that's how so many seats
were won at the Congressional level in
in the house in Congress by
conservatives so that the conservative
movement has really been at war with the
Republican establishment in this kind of
internal civil war for many many years
that Democrats haven't done it and I've
said from day one that Bernie Sanders in
the campaign against Hillary Clinton was
really the thing was raged you you kind
of tell that but I say it was like a
pillow fight he never really went after
her with all the material that was out
there about uranium one and it was in
Clinton cash so I think you're seeing
with the Donna Brazile revelations
really the beginning of the civil war in
the Democratic Party and and just now
shorty I mean in a blue state you say
the Democratic Party I yeah I think
they're gonna start I think I think
that's starting tonight I think it
started last night and I even won
election victory in a blue state like
Virginia is not going to be able to
gloss over that I think you're gonna see
Democrats in the progressive left really
go after the Wall Street cronies of
Clinton that control the Democratic
Party and I think they're gonna have a
lot of division the Democratic Party in
the years to come
all right stay right there we'll have
more with Steve Adam right after the